think about this real-world problem to
estimate the population of a town in
upcoming years one of the town workers
collected populations from past years
and made this table so they have year
starting with 1950 going up by
increments of 10 years and then you
figure out the population of the town in
each of those years the town wants to
estimate the population for 2015 2018
and 2020 to do this you will be will you
be using inductive reasoning or
deductive reasoning
now before answering that let's just
think about what inductive reasoning is
and what deductive reasoning it is
inductive reasoning is looking for a
pattern or looking for a trend so it's
looking for a trend or pattern and then
generalizing and then generalizing you
could imagine it's kind of extrapolating
the information you have generalizing
generalizing deductive reasoning is
taking some set of data or some set of
facts and using that to come up with
other or deducing some other facts that
you know are true when you generalize
you don't know necessarily whether the
trend is good will continue but you
assume it will you don't know 100% it'll
be true with deductive reasoning you
know it'll be true you're starting with
facts you're starting with facts and
then you're deducing other facts from
those facts other facts that you know
are true
now when the town is estimating and
that's a kind of a clue that they're not
going to know the exact population for
2015 2018 and 2020 but when they
estimate the population for these years
these years are in the future they don't
know what the Year what what the
population will be in those years the
best they can do is see the trend of
growth here maybe see how much what
percentage is growing every 10 years or
what the absolute number of growth is
every 10 years and maybe they can
continue that trend out to 2015 2018 and
2020 so they'll be looking for a trend
in growth over this 60-year period and
then they'll generalize it out to these
years so this will be inductive
reasoning this will be inductive
reasoning